ايه ده مشاهدينا في فيديو منتشر اله كم
يوم في من الصوت التواصل في مصر عامل حاله
من الاشتياق والحزن لكن القصه انتهت اليوم
نهايه سعيده الحمد لله خليني بالاول
اذكركم بالمقطع واللي ما شافوا اصلا عشان
يشوفوا
والله
وحياه ربنا العظيم
وحياه النبي وحياه ربنا
وحياه ربنا
حلفتك بالله عليك اكثر
لا اله الا الله
خلاص ياض انت حرام عليك يا ابني اوعي يا
عم مصطفى والله العظيم ما بهدلت حاجه
والله احب على راسك
طب استنى هيعمل
حراميه حرام
[موسيقى]
الفيديو اللي شفته مشاهدينا كان في
بورسعيد واللي ظاهر في رجل مسن بيعمل في
جمع البلاستيك من النفايات وهذا هو مصدر
رزقه لكن في شخص اتضح بعدين انه موظف رسمي
صادر العربي منه وعملوا مثل ما شفته
بطريقه اعتبرها كثار مهينه وموسيقى وبعدين
انتشار الفيديو وتصدر هاشتاج عامل نظافه
بورسعيد حقك علينا التران بعد ما تصدق
طبعا هذا الهاشتاج ترانس تحركت السلطات
الرسميه رئيس حي بورسعيد استدعى العامل
واعتذر منه واكد اي حاله الموظف للتحقيق
وكمان عرض عليه وظيفه للعمل في الحي لكسب
لقمه عيشه